joining me now live on the rich eisen
show is a pro football hall of famer
from his work for all those years
with the dallas cowboys the core former
quarterback of the three-time super bowl
champion dallas cowboys calling games
for fox
last week's win in seattle in this game
uh in dallas against the new york giants
troy aikman joining me on the program
how are you troy i'm good how you doing
rich i'm hanging in there thanks for
joining me i appreciate it what do you
think of these five-in-one cowboy how
about them cowboys
how about them cowboys
uh man i i'm like everyone else i didn't
expect much coming into the season i
i don't know how much they expected of
themselves rich to be quite honest with
you and then week one didn't get off to
a great start romo three interceptions
there and were down big at the half and
you know they squeaked out some games
they were down 21 at one point to st
louis in week three and and they wind up
winning that game and i think that with
each week they gained a little more
confidence
especially on the defensive side of the
ball to where
going into last week's game we thought
okay well you know likely they won't win
but at least we'll get a better feel as
to where exactly they are and uh and
they not only won but they dominated the
game and so
you know how it is that you know these
seasons it's hard to really determine
who are the contenders early in the
season but i think uh after that win
last week i think everyone would have to
agree that this team is
much better than than originally thought
and a team that certainly is capable of
contending within the conference well
they're hitting on every phase too troy
i mean they've got one of the best
kickers in the game as well and dan
bailey they've got a quarterback and
tony romo who's not making
the mistake that many people have come
to either i guess victim be victimized
by him for or love to poke fun of him
for he's been stellar and demarco murray
might be a reason why because they just
lean on him so it looks sustainable to
say the least the question is is how
demarco murray can stay standing on his
feet continuing the way that he's been
running the football yeah i think that's
the the real question and it is a
concern uh you know within the
organization it's not to demarco i i
know that when you
when you mention to him that he's
potentially injury prone which goes back
to his days at oklahoma you know he
really scoffs at that he doesn't like it
at all he's a tough guy he plays
physical and you know he doesn't want to
be labeled as a guy who gets injured but
yet he's not been able to make it
through a regular season i i think the
the staff would like to take a few
carries away from them they were able to
do that a little bit in the seattle game
i mean though even though he still
carried the ball a lot they got lance
dunbar involved they got joseph randall
involved but
i i think that's going to be important
as they move through the year but at the
same time you get into a game
on any given weekend and and you're just
focused on that game you're not worried
about trying to preserve anybody but you
know all the things that you mentioned
are good reasons as to why this team has
gotten to where they're at but you know
they drafted zach martin as their third
number one pick in the last four years
at the offensive line position and you
know there's this notion that okay well
we drafted zach martin so now we're
going to be a running team and we'll you
know they had a right guard there last
year and he wasn't maybe of the caliber
of zach martin but he was a good player
i i think more important to everything
that's been discussed has been
philosophically they have changed what
they're doing offensively and it's not
because they've got zach martin or you
know travis frederick at center or tyron
smith that left tackle you know they
went from being uh this the team that
ran the ball the second least per game
in the national football league a year
ago to now running the football
more than anybody and
so i think scott linehan deserves some
credit jason garrett certainly deserves
some credit but they have finally
said this is how we want to play and
we're going to stick to it regardless
and i think one of the reasons they've
been able to do that rich is because
they have taken some of the controls
away from romo you know think back to
last year you know jerry jones went into
the season after they gave him the big
contract and said hey we want him having
more control
and more ownership of this offense you
know much like what peyton manning has
so a lot of checks out of out of run
plays going to the pass so the running
numbers go down and i think the
mechanics of how they're operating have
changed and it's allowed them to
continue to run the football even when
maybe there's an extra guy at the line
of scrimmage and it's not conducive to
running interesting but it does also
help to have one of the best lines in
the business to to do that and or
michael irvin has said on game day
morning he said it to me privately this
line
is as good he's used those words as the
one that kept you upright and blew open
the holes for amit back in the day would
you agree with that troy
yeah i don't uh i don't really like
getting into comparisons i was asked
earlier today as a matter of fact uh if
this line is playing at the level that
our line played at and you know we had a
great offensive line and uh and so to
try to say yeah or you know wherever
they rank i don't know but i know
they're playing
they're playing really well you know
it's one thing to
it's one thing to draft these guys with
the first pick in each draft it's
another thing to get the picks right and
that's what they've been able to do i
mean they've hit
on all three of these and so you know
they have they have run the ball well
it's taken a lot of pressure off romo
it's really helped that defense the
defense has played much better than
anyone anticipated
but because of the things that they're
doing running the ball uh it's keeping
the defense on the sidelines more and
it's keeping them from being exposed in
some areas where maybe they're not a
real strength but uh it's been it's it's
it is the same style that we had you
know and jason garrett has been
preaching for the last several years
that hey he was influenced by the
success that he saw of our teams in the
90s and how that was a blueprint for him
but yet it hasn't carried over to the
way that they've called plays and this
year it finally is and it's a formula
that's won a lot of football games in
this league for a lot of years and now
come the giants into the house that uh
jerry built that they like to say they
really own they've won every time except
once coming into that spot
and just when people start counting the
giants out this is the type of game that
they win although last sunday night was
brutal troy i don't know how much film
you've been able to see so far midweek
but what what happened
to the giants in eli last week well it's
funny you say that because i i just
turned on the film and i and i'm i'm
about four plays into the giants offense
right now they look really good right
i know it doesn't continue it goes
downhill from here i don't mean to ruin
it for you but the pass of the game was
really nice protection and then after
that you know you like got six sec six
times so
you know it's uh they've got to be
better it it's been a roller coaster for
this team as we know they the the first
couple of weeks new offense just looked
terrible and uh then they pulled it
together and looked good the next three
weeks and rallied like you kind of would
have expected the giants to do and and
then they got embarrassed uh against the
eagles which the eagles are capable of
doing that but
i do think that what you said is
accurate that
you know even though there's some
different faces it is still the same
quarterback it's the same head coach and
they come to dallas having had success
at this stadium they've only lost one
time
uh and knowing the giants the way i do
and having covered this team for so many
years
i do expect them to rally even without
victor cruz it's a huge loss and a lot
of guys are going to have to step up and
and play really well to feel that void
uh but i do expect it to be a good game
i i heck i expect every game to be good
but i i do think this will be fun to
watch how about the nfc east troy we're
talking nfc east and it's it's it's
viable it's viable it's it's it's
current it's what people are talking
about because the football is good in
that division mostly yeah you know i i
didn't really expect much from this
division going in i i thought
philadelphia would would about have the
thing wrapped up already you know i mean
i thought they were heading shoulders
above everybody and you know they've
been able to win some games when they
haven't played their best uh the giants
they rallied they're back in the thick
of it this becomes a huge game you know
for them they they can he'll afford to
to go down three games you know this
early in the season and then having lost
already to philadelphia into dallas
that's why i think that they're going to
play really well and then dallas being
where they're at so
you know all of a sudden a division that
didn't look like it'd be real
competitive has has turned into one of
the stronger divisions in all of
football
cowboys eagles play on thanksgiving day
for the first time that'll be fun uh
before i let you go i want to talk about
two guys are going to be in the bust
room with you one day wearing yellow
jackets with you one day
um favre is going to have his record
broken if not this sunday then next
thursday
by peyton manning the number 509
for career touchdowns troy how
mind-boggling is that
to you hall of fame quarterback
wow
it's pretty mind-blowing to me uh you
know we've
i thought this one favre was playing and
i played against him and competed
against him in some huge games and and
then had a chance to broadcast a lot of
his games and
you know i remember watching him when
when he was winding down his career yet
was still playing at a very high level
and i said wow this is one of those
players that we're going to talk about
in the same breath that we currently
talk about you know johnny unitas and
and those types of guys and
and it was a real pleasure to get a
chance to broadcast a lot of those games
and watch him play each and every
weekend and
and when he left i i really did not
think a lot of those records that he has
would be broken and you know here peyton
is and and he's going to do it in fewer
games and it it speaks a lot to how the
game has changed but
you know what i always said about emmitt
smith haven't had the pleasure of
playing with him and watching him you
know do what he was able to do and
now he's the all-time lead in rusher it
you obviously have to play a high level
to get to that point but not only do you
have to play at a really high level but
you have to do it for a long period of
time and you can't miss games and so i i
think it's one of the greatest things as
a teammate when you can rely on your
teammate being there to play and play
well each and every weekend and that's
what the teammates could expect to farve
and that's what peyton manning's
teammates can expect from him he comes
out he plays at a high level but he
plays each and every week and other than
that one year when he missed because of
his neck he's been out there doing it uh
it's been a lot of fun he's a it's nice
when with all the negative stuff that
we've seen you know come about within
our game when there are guys like peyton
manning who represents the game so well
and plays the game the way that you hope
your kids will play if they go on and
play and uh it's been uh it's been a
pleasure and i i don't know that
you know he's going to be done uh
you know after this year i still see him
playing a few more years and i think
we're going to see more and more of that
because of the rules with a lot of these
quarterbacks i think we're going to see
a lot of guys playing right up until
they're about 40 years old sure and as
you know uh your former teammate is mine
every sunday in irvine and um it it's my
job to set him up to make plays sort of
like you
and it's my job to sort of get to break
on time sometimes troy i'm having issues
doing that yeah good luck i i saw
i saw irvin after the big cowboys win
last sunday when i got back from seattle
i was able to watch the the late
post-game show
he was pretty fired up about the cowboy
he's feeling it and when dezz dez is
wearing his number come on yeah
he ought to just wear his jersey in
studio this week
that may come certainly if they keep
winning troy thanks for joining me i
hope this becomes a regular thing i'd
love it hey love it thanks rich you bet
that's troy aikman hall of famer the
rich eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience